اما في بيجين فقالت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه ماونينج ان بلادها تتحقق
من المعلومات المتعلقه بالمنطاد الذي
رصدته الولايات المتحده في اجوائها وتشتبه
في انه لاغراض استخباريه واضافت
دوله مسؤوله وتلتزم بالقانون الدولي وليس
لها ايونيه لانتهاك اراضي اي دوله اخرى او
مجالها الجوي
د
يتابع التقارير بشان قضيه المنطاد ونتحقق
من الموقف التخمين لا يفضي الى الحل
المناسب الصين دوله مسؤوله وتلتزم دائما
بالقانون الدولي وليس لديها نيه لانتهاك
اراضي اي دوله او مجالها الجوي نامل ان
يعمل الجانبان معا بهدوء وحذر
بولونيا والخبير في الشؤون الصينيه
والاسيويه دكتور منطاد بهذا الحجم من من
السهل يعني اكتشافه كيف نفهم عمليه تجسس
صينيه بهذه الطريقه في الاجواء الكنديه
والامريكيه بحسب المزاعم الامريكيه
انا هناك محاوله من قبل الصين لجمع
المعلومات بشان مواقع حساسه مثل مونتانا
حيث انه هناك عدد من الصواريخ الباليستيه
عابره للقارات وبالتالي هذه المرحله هي
تعتبر مرحله توتر كبيره ما بين الدولتين
هي مرحله مهمه لان هناك حساسيه تجري في
الولايات المتحده بشكل التحديات الامنيه
التي تشكلها الصين وهناك قضيه اخرى مهمه
داخليا في الوقت الحالي فان السياسه في
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعاني من
استقطاب كما راينا على سبيل المثال كيف ان
كان احد هؤلاء الذين سلطت الضوء واكد على
الخطر تمثله الصين وكذلك الجهود الصين
لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه بشان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مرحله التوتر هذه
الازمه ربما قد تستمر وهي ربما قد تكون
مهمه جدا
هي مرحله حساسه توقيت حساس لا خلاف على
ذلك ولكن موقف الصين حاليا يحتاج الى وقفه
الصين حتى الان لا تنفي ولا تؤكد هذه
المزاعم الامريكيه ما تفسير في تقديره
ربما ما اراه هو ان كلا الطرفين
يحتاجان التعلق كيفيه التعامل واداره
الازمات ربما الصين قد ارسلته اخمن واقول
ذلك لكن كلا البلدين
يحاولان احتواء التبعات السياسيه التي
ربما قد تصل الى مرحله الازمه
اذا كل من بيجين
والولايات المتحده كلاهما يقرران بان هناك
منافسه استراتيجيه واقتصاديه ما بين
الدولتين وبالتالي لابد ان يتمكن من اداره
هذه الازمه وهذا اختبار واذا ما فعلت ذلك
الصين فان الولايات المتحده تحتاج كذلك ان
تتعامل مع التبعات السلبيه لهذه الازمه
وهذه تعتبر طريقه مره اخرى
نعم تماما تماما هذه هي المرحله التي بها
اعتراف حقيقي ان هناك منافسه وهناك كذلك
اقرار على ان هناك الضروره بالنسبه
للطرفين ليتعامل مع الكثير من التحديات
والكثير من المواضيع هذه الازمه ستجعل
الموضوع اكثر تعقيدا بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده خصوصا لتجد ارضيه مشتركه مع الصين
بشان القضايا المختلفه بما في ذلك وكوريا
الشماليه غزو
روسيا لاوكرانيا موضوع تايوان هناك الكثير
من المواضيع التي لدى البلدين مواقف
مختلفه
ومفروض والارضيه المشتركه بين البلدين
تقتضي ان لا يتم التصعيد ما بينهما
وبالتالي هذه المساله ليست فقط مهمه من
الناحيه الامنيه وانما تخفف من مستوى
الثقه التي قد تكون لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تجاه الصين وكذلك يؤدي الى مزيد
من استقطاب بشان كيفيه التعامل مع الصين
شكرا لك اذا من روما الدكتور ماتيوديان
الاستاذ بجامعه بولونيا والخبير في الشؤون
الصينيه والاسيويه